يعد حزب الرفاه من جديد ابرز الرابحين
يدخل البرلمان للمره الاولى بخمسه مقاعد
من بينها مقعد لرئيسه فاتح نجم الدين
اربكان ضمن لوائح تحالف الجمهور بزعامه
رجب طيب اردوغان حزب الحركه القوميه يعد
ايضا من ابرز الرابحين نال 50 مقعدا منها
مقاعد كانت سابقا من حصه حليفه حزب
العداله والتنميه ومكن فوزه تحالف الجمهور
من الحفاظ على اغلبيه برلمانيه وبعد
انضمام حزب الديمقراطيه والتقدم برئاسه
علي بابا جان الى تحالف الشعب وخوض
الانتخابات على لوائح حزب الشعب الجمهوري
نال حزب الديمقراطيه والتقدم المعروف
بدافع 14 مقعدا كانت في الاساس من حصه
الشعب الجمهوري الحاله نفسها تكررت مع حزب
المستقبل بزعامه احمد داوود اوغلو الذي
حصد عشره مقاعد اقتطعها
حليفه حزب الشعب الجمهوري حزب السعاده خضر
الانتخابات البرلمانيه ضمن تحالف الشعب
واوصل عشره نواب للبرلمان مقابل مقعدين
عام 2018
وتمكن تحالف الجمهور من الحصول على اغلبيه
برلمانيه بحصده
323 مقعدا اي حوالي 49 ونصف في المئه من
الاصوات رغم خسارته الاغلبيه في العاصمه
انقره ومدينه اسطنبول ومن المفاجات التي
انتجتها الانتخابات التركيه بروز سنان
اوغان الذي تحول من سياسي مخمور في تيار
القوميين الى مرشح رئاسي عن تحالف الاجداد
بحصوله على
25% اي حوالي ثلاثه ملايين صوت
تحالف العمل والحريه التي يجمع حزبي
اليسار الاخضر والعمال التركي بخمسه وستين
مقعدا ومقارنه بنتيجه الحزب الكردي الاكبر
الشعوب الديمقراطي الذي لم ياخذ هذه
الانتخابات خسر هذا التكتل مقعدين وعلى
الرغم من تسجيل التيارات القوميه حضورا
بارزا فان حزب النصر المعادي للاجئين مني
بخساره كبيره فقد فشل في تخطي عتبه سبعه
في المئه لدخول البرلمان وفقد بالتالي
رئيسه اوميت اوزداد المقعد البرلماني اما
تحالف الشعب المعارض فمني بخساره في عدد
مقاعده وذهبت الى احزاب صغيره حزب الجيد
الذي يندرج ضمن تحالف الشعب المعارض بدوره
يعد من الخاسرين ولم يتمكن من احراز اي
مقاعد جديده رغم الحملات الدعائيه المكثفه
لرفع حصه الحزب في البرلمان وعلى الرغم من
نيل تحالف الجمهور اغلبيه برلمانيه بفوزه
ب 300 وثلاثه وعشرين مقعدا فان حصه
العداله والتنميه تراجعت الى
288 مقعدا ومن ضمن الخاسرين محرم انجي
الذي شغل سابقا مناصب حزبيه ونيابيه عن
حزب الشعب الجمهوري وترشح عن الحزب في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2018
وحصل على 30% من الاصوات تقريبا
ترشح في هذه الانتخابات عن حزبه الجديد
وانسحب قبل الاقتراع بثلاثه ايام وفشل في
ايصال نواب للبرلمان